Okay.
Let's look at negative powers of ten. Okay, remember, zero is neither positive
nor negative. But, my first negative power would be 10 to the negative 1, then I
have 10 to the negative 2, or 10 to the negative 3. I know 10 to the 0 is 1,
because anything to the 0 power is 1. For negative exponents, remember, I take
the reciprocal of the number. So, I have 1 10th to the 1, or 1 10th. For 10 to
the negative 2, I have 1 10th squared, or 1 10th times 1 10th, which is 100th.
For 10 to the negative 3, I have the reciprocal of 10, because the exponent's
negative. And it becomes a three. 1 10th cubed is just 1 10th times 1 10th times
1 10th, or 1 1000th. So, I have 1, I have 1 10th. 1 10th is the same thing as
the decimal point 1 because the 1 is in the tenth spot. 1 100th here, it's 01.
because the 1 is in the hundredth's place. And then, I have 1 1000th. I know
it's 1 1000th because the 1 is in the thousandth space.